[Music]
as we saw during the jubilee for some
time prince charles has stepped in for
the queen and in 10 days he'll deputise
in rwanda representing her as head of
the commonwealth
it could be awkward the times newspaper
reports he made private yet highly
critical comments about the uk's rwandan
policy
describing it appalling that he was
disappointed and unimpressed with the
government's plan we're looking forward
to welcoming uh
all the leaders and all the delegates a
spokesperson for the rwandan government
wouldn't be drawn on the comments
i think people need to give this
partnership a chance
um it's it's very well thought out
uh it's going to be well resourced we
are determined to make this work we have
the experience we're building the
capacity to do this properly so everyone
just needs to to give this a chance to
work
he's forcefully fought for environmental
issues and famously lobby tony blair's
government his letters monitored the
black spider memos but as future monarch
does it matter not at all this is a
storm in a tea cup the prince of wales
is perfectly entitled to speak to
ministers and others on a private and
discrete basis and they're under an
obligation
not to repeat his comments in public
anyone who does so is doing a disservice
to the monarchy but some say he's
overstepped this time prince has a very
difficult job because the job is not
defined and he has been
in that role now the heir for a very
long time
but it is
dismaying to see that he may be verging
into territory which he has hitherto
been understood to wish to keep out of
clarence house insists the prince
remains politically neutral
but these comments although private
don't seem impartial and the fact
they've been made public will be
embarrassing especially coming so close
to a royal visit and the first ever to
rwanda
and so close to to the first migrants
being flown into the country housed in
hotels like this one
campaigners will appeal the judgment on
monday
the coincidence of the commonwealth trip
means scrutiny was expected but perhaps
not in this way laura bundock sky news